اوكرانيا تحت ضغوط هائله على المدى القصير
من داعمها الغربيين بحسب نيويورك تايمز
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها يعتبرون الهجوم
المضاد اختبارا حاسما لمعرفه ما اذا كانت
الاسلحه والتدريب وذخيره التي ارسلها
الكياف خلال الاشهر الاخيره ستتم ترجمتها
الى مكاسب على ارض المعركه فاوكرانيا بحسب
الصحيفه تخاطر بتقليص الدعم الغربي لها ان
كان الهجوم المضاد اقل من التوقعات عقب
مليارات الاسلحه والتدريب التي حصلت عليها
وقد ترزح تحت ضغط قبول المفاوضات في حال
فشلها في تحقيق تطلعات الغرب وما زاد
المخاوف الغربيه تصريحات وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني اوليكسي ريزني كوفا ان شركاء
اوكرانيا يبالغون في تقدير توقع الهجوم
المضاد مضيفا ان هذه المبالغه تقلق
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات